welcome back to Rocket Riley let's break
down everything from the lucasfilm panel
at d23 including never before seen
images and Premiere dates for Star Wars
tales of the Jedi Ahsoka the Mandalorian
and Indiana Jones 5. and stay tuned to
the end for one Star Wars announcement
that was made in a separate panel
[Music]
starting with the first big announcement
at this year's d23 Expo lucasfilm
revealed a new trailer for their
upcoming series and door arriving on
Disney Plus on September 21st with a
three episode premiere this is the first
series to premiere on Disney plus with
three episodes typically coming to the
platform with one or two episodes on
launch day starring Diego Luna Andor is
going to completely change the way we
think about Star Wars but I won't get
into it too much if you want more
details on the show check out my Andor
video linked below the next big
announcement at the lucasfilm panel
surrounded Star Wars tales of the Jedi
first announced at Star Wars celebration
in 2022. this show is a six part
animated short series confirmed to be
arriving to Disney Plus on October 26
2022. Dave filoni made the announcement
and debuted its first trailer featuring
looks at young Ahsoka Tano an early
Qui-Gon Gentile Count Dooku and more
this series will fill in many gaps in
Ahsoka Tano's life and will give a
better backstory on how Count Dooku fell
from the Jedi Order I'll say this is
probably the upcoming project that I'm
most excited about next Dave filoni and
John Favreau treated fans in attendance
at d23 to select early in production
images from Ahsoka the upcoming Disney
plus series starring Rosario Dawson as
the wandering former Jedi they also
announced that Ahsoka is set to arrive
on Disney Plus in 2023 while they didn't
give much information about the show
itself Dave filoni did hint that we will
likely get to see a live-action Sabine
Wren in the series rumors have also
stated that amanus fondi has been tapped
to play Ezra Bridger in the Ahsoka
series but lucasfilm has declined to
comment on this as of yet up next the
cast of Willow including the titular
wizard himself Warwick Davis gathered
for a discussion about the fresh new
take on the upcoming Disney plus series
Willow following the story of the
original movie Davis and Company debuted
their original poster and trailer in and
a surprise that delighted everyone in
attendance the legendary Christian
Slater joined the panel confirming he's
also joined the cast of Willow executive
producer Dave filoni then confirmed that
the second season of the bad batch will
arrive on January 4th 2023 with a two
episode premiere on Disney plus so clone
Force 99 is back as season 2 opens
months have passed since the events on
kamino and the bad batch will continue
their Journey navigating the Empire
after the fall of the Republic they'll
cross paths with friends and foes both
new and familiar as they take on a
variety of thrilling mercenary missions
that'll take them to unexpected and
dangerous new places quick plug if you
like what you're seeing hit that
subscribe button to see more videos like
this now on to the next d23 announcement
currently in production Star Wars
Skeleton Crew will center around a group
of children Lost in Space and it'll be
set in the new Republic time frame
creators John Watts and Chris Ford
joined John Favreau and Dave filoni to
present an in-room only first look at
Jude Law in the show and also welcome
the actor on stage I've tried to get a
recording of this first look but I
haven't been able to find it if any of
you are able to find it drop a comment
below up next the Mandalorian Creator
John Favreau executive producer Dave
filoni and star Pedro Pascal took the
stage to talk about the Mandalorian
premiering a teaser trailer for The
long-awaited season 3 premiering in 2023
see season 3 follows up on the events of
the book of Boba Fett which saw grogu
choose to return to Mando after
previously departing his side to train
with the Jedi Master Luke Skywalker the
two then left Tatooine with Mando going
on a quest to visit the Living Waters
under the planet Mandalore in order to
regain his honor and become a
Mandalorian once again this season is
sure to take us further into the history
and lore of the mandalorians and I'm so
excited to see how Mandalore looks
following the Great Purge now grab your
Fedora and whip the fifth Indiana Jones
film arrives June 30th 2023 exclusively
in theaters and director James Mangold
was joined by stars Harrison Ford and
Phoebe Waller bridge to debut in in room
only Sizzle reel again I won't get too
far into this since I've already made a
video breaking down everything we know
about Indiana Jones 5. if you want to
see more check out this video Linked In
the description below now that we know
everything announced in the lucasfilm
panel let's get into the Star Wars
announcement made in a separate panel
Jamal Avery Jr and Emma Berman were
announced to voice Kai bright star and
Nash Durango in the upcoming series Star
Wars young Jedi Adventures Kai
BrightStar is a Jedi youngling who hopes
to grow in the ways of the force and
follow in the footsteps of Master Yoda
Nash Durango is a pilot who befriends
Cayenne company joining them on
adventures across the Galaxy the
Animated Series set during the high
Republic era will arrive on Disney Plus
in 2023. now all of these announcements
definitely got me excited for 2023 and I
can't wait for Andor to drop in just a
few days which announcement are you most
excited for drop your thoughts in the
comment section below also check out the
video on your screen for some more of my
content don't forget to like And
subscribe and thanks for watching Rocket
Riley
foreign